احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه ودائما سنخصص معظمها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان كالعاده نبدا
بابرز العناوين
اشتباكات مستمره في السودان وخارجيه
السودان تتحدث عن موافقه مبدئيه من طرفي
الصراع على هدنه لاسبوع
مبعوث البرهان يؤكد من القاهره ان الهدنه
الحاليه انسانيه ولا اتفاق او مفاوضات مع
قوات الدعم
ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا المدنيين في السودان
والتحضيرات امميه من تداعيات الصراع على
المنطقه
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
كيف تتحدث عن تراجع روسي في باخموت وموسكو
تقول ان اوكرانيا خسرت 15 الفا من
مقاتليها خلال شهر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من مناطق في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مشهد مات
مالوفا فرغم الهدن المعلنه لا تزال
الاشتباكات والقصف المتبادل بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وفيما يدور حديث عن
هدنه جديده لاسبوع بموافقه مبدئيه من
الطرفين اكد الجيش ان الهدف من الهدن
المعلنه انساني ولا تفاوض مع قوات الدعم
[موسيقى]
طبعا كل المراكز عطله بحال الحرب الدائره
الان نحن برامز ظروف الحاضر
نعمل في هذه الظروف الصعبه وعدم امكانيات
اللي ما موجوده هنا
سحب بعض الادويه والمعدات
في التفاصيل اعلنت وزاره خارجيه جنوب
السودان ان رئيس المجلس السياده السوداني
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وفقا من حيث
المبدا على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا يوم
الخميس المقبل وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان
البرهان ودجلو وفقا ايضا خلال اتصالا
هاتفي مع رئيس جنوب السودان سلفاكار على
تسميه ممثلين عنهما للمشاركه في محادثات
سلام تعقد في مكان من اختيارهما
الى ذلك قال السفير دفع الله الحاج مبعوث
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني الى الجيش
السودانيه تعاطى مع الهدنه على اساس انها
هدنه انسانيه نافيا ان يكون هناك اي تفاوض
مع قوات الدعم السريع
مفهومنا الان فيما يتعلق بالهدنه هي هدنه
انسانيه
ليست هنالك ليس هنالك حديث عن
اي اتفاق ولا تفاوض مباشر مع المليشيا
المتمرده نعم اقول لك نحن
الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي
للاطلاع بدور فيما يتعلق بهذه الهدنه
والدول التي بادرت بها وهي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ونامل ان يكون للجامعه العربيه ثغلا ووزنا
وخاصه ان الاخ الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه قد عبر عن مشاعر
مؤيده للشرعيه في السودان منذ اليوم الاول
في هذا الاثناء وانا اتحدث معكم صدر قرار
من الجامعه العربيه
نص القرار على
التاكيد على الشرعيه في السودان وهي شرعيه
القوات المسلحه كمؤسسه وطنيه مسؤوله من
حمايه امن واستقرار السودان
القرار نصه ايضا على وطالبه باخلاء قوات
الدعم السريع للمستشفيات التي تحتلها وعدم
الارتكاز فيها وعدم
اتخاذ العاملين في المجال الطبي دروعا
بشريه
وبخصوص العمليه السياسيه وعدم مبعوثه رئيس
مجلس السياده السودانيه
في عمليه سياسيه شامله لا يقصى منها احد
اؤكد لكم انه عندما تنجلي هذه الازمه
قريبا
وتتحقق
وتسيطر الشرعيه في البلاد
سيكون الامر
خلافه ما كان عليه بمعنى ان يتم
الدخول
وترتيب عمليه سياسيه واسعه شامله
لا يتم فيها اقصاء اي من الكائنات
السياسيه السودانيه الا ما سبق ان اتفق
عليه السودانيين للتمهيد
للانتقال الديمقراطي الحر
[موسيقى]
من جانبه قال عضو مجلس السياده السوداني
الفريق اول ياسر العطا في تصريحات خاصه
للعربيه ان الجيش يسيطر على السودان مشيرا
الى ان الدعم السريع يحتمي بوجوده
بالاحياء المدنيه المكتظه بالمدنيين وله
قناصه لحمايته متحدثا عن خطه استراتيجيه
للقضاء عليه خلال اسبوعين على حد قوله
وصلت المعارك لسيطره كامله على كل ربوع
السوداني
ادى جيوب غليله في ولايتين اما العاصمه
القوميه والتي تم حجز معظم قوات الخونه
والاعمال المتمردين فيها فلا زالت المعارك
جاهزه وقواتنا المسلحه متوازنه ومتماسكه
تحقق انتصارات متتاليه على العدو المتمرد
تمثل التي يحتمي قوات التمرد فهو يحتمل
بمنازل المواطنين المدنيين وبعض
المستشفيات وبعض المدارس خاصه في الاحياء
المختصه بالمدنيين ايضا احتمائهم وفي
مناطق فيها منشات حيويه
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت الصور استهداف طيران الجيش
السوداني لاهداف وتمركزات تابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع نتابع يلا
[موسيقى]
بالمقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
لها انها اسقطت طائره من طراز ميك تابعه
للجيش السوداني في الخرطومه وذكرت قوات
الدعم السريع انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها
الجيش السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق
سكنيه في الخرطوم
نشر حساب وورما المتخصص بالخرائط الحربيه
خريطه لمنطقه المعارك في الخرطوم اليوم
الثلاثاء حيث تظهر الخريطه سيطره واضحه
للجيش في اغلب مناطق العاصمه خصوصا من جهه
الشمال في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم تظهر
الخريطه حاله تجاذب بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في وقت تتوسع سيطره قوات الدعم
باتجاه جنوب العاصمه
من الخرطوم ما ينضم الى مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي يبدو سالم بانه غير جاهز
معنا وانما نتابع الان هذه الصور المباشره
من الخرطوم حيث نتابع سويا هذا الدخان
المتصاعد في سماء الخرطوم على كل حال يعني
منذ الاسبوع الماضي ودائما عندما نلتقط
صور مباشره دائما في هذه المنطقه بالذات
دائما الدخان يتصاعد فيبدو بانه
الاشتباكات هناك دائما
متقطعه ودائما تستهدف هذه المنطقه اذا ما
زلنا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره لكاميرا
العربيه من الخرطوم حيث نتابع سويا تصاعد
الدخان في سماء الخرطوم حيث على الرغم من
هذه الهدنه والى حد ما الالتزام بها من
وقت لاخر حيث الناس في بعض الاحياء وبعض
المناطق استطاعوا ان يتحركوا ويعودوا الى
حياتهم الطبيعيه ولكن دائما الاشتباكات ما
زالت متقطعه دائما الطيران طيران الجيش
السوداني يحلق في السماء وتسمع ايضا
مضادات من قبل قوات الدعم السريع لاستهداف
هذه الطائرات
اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع
بسرقه سيارات المواطنين والمغادره بها الى
خارج الخرطوم وطلب الجيش السوداني
المواطنين الانتباه لسياراتهم لانها اصبحت
محل استهداف من جهه اخرى نفذت قوات الدعم
السريع هذه الاتهامات معتبره انها محاوله
للوقيع بينها وبين المواطنين لكن الجيش لن
يتمكن من ذلك على حد وصفها كما اتهمت قوات
الجيش بقصف عدد من المرافق الخدميه
بالطائرات
وفي اطار المطالبات السودانيه المدنيه
بالتفاوض على ياسر عرمان الناطق الرسمي
باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان الى
مظاهرات واسعه في المناطق غير المتاثره
بالصراع للدفع نحو التفاوض ووقف الحرب
واكد علمان ان القرى والمدن التي لا
تشملها الحرب عليها ان تخرج بشكل واسع
للدفع للتفاوض ووقف الحرب في البلاد مؤكدا
ان التفاوض سيقود البلاد الى القضايا التي
طرحت للمعالجه في الاتفاق الايطالي قائلا
انه لابد من قوات مسلحه مهنيه واحده وحكم
مدني في السودان
قبل ذلك اقترح رئيس الوزراء السوداني
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش والدعم السريه لتوفير الاساس
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
الاتفاق على انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه
واقترح حمدوك ايضا اشراك المدنيين
السودانيين في مفاوضات شامله واستئناف
العمليه السياسيه مؤكدا على ان استمرار
الحرب في السودان وانتشارها في رقعه او
ساقد يضر العالم باسره
اتحركنا من يوم الاربع من الخرطوم فكان
المعساه يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد احنا 28
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم عشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت الادانات
من تحت الدرب فنانه من يعني طلعنا من
الاجوبه بتاع التوتر والضرب لحد ما وصلنا
قالت المتحدثه باسم مكتب المفوض السامي
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين والقسارادو
ان اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ عبروا من السودان
الى الدول المجاوره هربا من الصراع بينما
نجح مئات الالاف بسبب العنف داخل البلاد
سوف تشير التفسيرات الى ان اكثر من 100
الف لاجئ هم من بين اولئك الذين فروا من
السودان الى البلدان
ويشمل هذا الرقم ايضا اللاجئين في جنوب
السودان المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين حددت الى جانب الحكومات
والشركاء رقم تخطيط اولي لاكثر من 800 اي
فلاجئ وعائد قد يفررون من السودان الى
البلدان المجاوره
المتحدث باسم المنظمه الدوليه للهجره قال
بدوره ان عدد الناسي حين ارتفع بوتيره
سريعه في الاسبوعين الماضيين بسبب القتال
المتواصل بين المكونين العسكريين
نزح ما لا يقل عن
334 الف شخص داخليا نتيجه الصراع الحاصل
وفقا لتقرير شبكه قياس تتبع النزوح
التابعه للمنظمه الدوليه للهجره ارتفع عدد
النازحين خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين نتيجه
تواصل الصراع في السودان جميع حالات
النزوح مرتبطه بالظروف الصعبه والازمات
التي زادت منذ عام 2022
هربا من شبح الموت والدمار لجا اكثر من
مئه الف سوداني الى دول مجاوره
سيدفعهم 700 الف اخرون وذلك بحسب توقع
الامم المتحده اما داخليا فتخطى عدد
النازحين
334 الف سوداني توجه اغلبه من الخرطوم
مركز الحرب الدائره الى القرى والولايات
المجاوره جنوب السودان وتشاد ومصر ابرز
وجهات اللاجئين بحكم الحدود المشتركه
الحدود المصريه التي استقبلت اكثر من 15
الف لاجئ سوداني بات معبر قسط الاشكيت
البري القريب من مدينه حلفا السودانيه
المعبر المفضل للاجئين السودانيين
المتجهين الى مصر وذلك بسبب انعدام
الخدمات في الجانب السوداني من الخيار
الاخر معبر ارجين بالاضافه الى وجود
القنصليه المصريه التي تصدر تاشيرات دخول
المواطنين من الرجال السودانيين من سن 16
عاما وحتى 50 عاما
فاستقبلت حتى الان اكثر من عشرين الف لاجئ
سوداني اغلبهم من اقليم دارفور وهو نفس
عدد اللاجئين تقريبا الذين فروا الى جنوب
السودان معظمهم من السودانيين الذين
يعيشون بالحزام الفاصل بين الجارتين
بالاضافه الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه لاجئ
اتجهوا الى اثيوبيا عبر معبر الجلابات في
ولايه القضارف العدد الاقل كان الى
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
1500 لاجئ نظرا لكون الحدود بين البلدين
مغلقه
اعلنت ولايه البحر الاحمر وسنار
السودانيتان حاله الطوارئ لمده شهر بحسب
وكاله انباء السودان وكان والي البحر
الاحمر المكلف ففتح الله الحاج اصدر امرا
بحظر نقل السلع الاستراتيجيه خارج حدود
الولايه الا بموافقه الجهات المختصه
ينضم الي الان من مدينه بورتسودان وراس
العربيه نزاره البكداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا
الوضع لديك وكيف هي اعداد النازحين
وعمليات الاجلاء كيف ترصدها لليوم
نبدا بالوضع الامني والخدمي والتنميه
والتنموي هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر
تحديدا في عاصمتها مدينه بورسودان الاوضاع
الامنيه الان مستقره الاوضاع الخدميه الان
هنالك لجنه مكونه من قبل حكومه ولايه
البحر الاحمر تتابع عن كثب كل الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والتنمويه والخدميه تم اقرار
حاله الطوارئ هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر
لمده 30 يوما تبدا من يوم الامس ولمده شهر
كامل ايضا للتعاطي والتعامل مع كل الاوضاع
المترتبه على الذي خلفته الاحداث الاخيره
في السودان
سلطه حكومه البحر الاحمر تقول بانها
ستتعامل بجديه مع كل الملفات الخدميه
والتنمويه والصحيه حتى تعبر البلاد وحتى
تعبر ولايه البحر الاحمر هذه المرحله
باعتبارها اصبحت منفذا بحريا وجويا لمئات
من الاسر والالاف الرعايه الدول الاجنبيه
الذين يغادرون السودان عبر بوابه شرق
السودان فيما يلي عمليه الاجلاء هذا هو
اليوم الحادي عشر لهذه العمليه التي بدات
منذ الحادي والعشرين من شهر ابريل المنصرم
عبر ميناء بورسودان ويوم الثالث والعشرين
من ابريل في ذات الشهر عبر مطار بورسودان
الدولي الذي استقبل اكثر من اربعين او
سبعين رحله جويه اقلت اكثر من
6500 شخص انتقلوا من مطار بورسودان الى
عدد من الوجهات الدوليه منها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه والافريقيه والدول المغاربيه
اما هنا على السبيل العمل المتعلق بميناء
بورسودان من خلف مباشره فحتى اليوم نتحدث
عن 25 رحله بحريه لسفن حربيه وقطع بحريه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كان لها الن
الاكبر من هذه القطع بحكم التنسيق المستمر
والمباشر لسفاره مملكه العربيه السعوديه
هنا في السودان مع عدد من البعثات الدوليه
التي تنسق باستمرار مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومع وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
بهدف تسهيل مهمه اجلاء عدد من الرعايه
التابعين لعدد من الدول في سياق ايضا متصل
هنالك مئات من الاسر السوريه واليمنيه ما
زالت موجوده في مدينه بورسودان تنتظر ايضا
توفيق الاوضاع هنالك ايضا مئات من
السودانيين ينتظرون ايضا توفيق الاوضاع هم
من الذين يحملون الاقامات ويحملون ايضا
زيارات لعدد من الدول العربيه والخليجيه
ينتظرون ايضا ان يتم استخراج الجوازات ان
تنسق لهم القنصليه هنا في مدينه بورسودان
الاجراءات وبعدها يغادرون عبر مطار
بورسودان او عبره ميناء بورسودان الى المم
لكه العربيه السعوديه واذا عدد من دول
المنطقه والخليج العربي
نزار عن المواطنين في بورسودان يعني ايضا
الاوضاع هناك خاصه الاقتصاديه يعني ليست
بالجيده كيف
يتعاملون مع عمليه هذا النزوح حتى ولو
لايام قليله قبل الاجلاء
في الحقيقه مدينه بورسودان هي مدينه
اقتصاديه بامتياز وهي مدينه ساحليه وهي
مدينه سياحيه ياتي اليها السودانيون في
اوقات متعدده ياتي اليها السياح والاجانب
ياتي ايضا اليها من يحب ان يمارس سياحه
الغطس والسياحه هذه المدينه الان اقتصاديا
شهدت حاله من الازدهار عكس ما كان متوقع
نسبه للاعداد الكبيره مئات الاسر والاف من
رعايه الدول الاجنبيه دخلت الى بورسودان
دخلت الى سوق المدينه انعشت ايجار الشقق
السكنيه الفنادق كل هذا الامر احدث حراكا
اقتصاديا حتى الباعه الجائلون وجدوا متسعا
لبيع بضاعاتهم نسبه ايضا لوجود مئات الاسر
التي تاتي امام مقر
المقر الرئيسي لاجراءات وحصر يريد ان
يغادر السودان هنالك ايضا ملمح اخر يتعلق
بالتكاتف المجتم للمنظمات الشبابيه
والمنظمات الطوعيه وسكان مدينه بورسودان
الذين قدموا اللوحه اجتماعيه وصفت هنا
بانها باهره وبانها سودانيه بامتياز
استضافوا كثير من الاسر السوريه واليمنيه
ورحبوا بهم وبسط لهم بسطوا لهم فراش
المحبه والتحنان والموده باعتبار ان
البلاد تمر بازمه وان من وصلوا الى مدينه
بورسودان يستحقون كل الاحتفاء وكل الموده
حتى يغادروا هذه المنطقه بامان وبسلام
شكرا لك نزال البرداوي كنت معي من
بورتسودان مراسل العربيه على كل هذه
التفاصيل وعلى هذه الصوره الواضحه حقيقه
لما يجري في بورتسودان
ادى القتال في السودان الى نزوح عشرات
الالاف من الاشخاص عبر النياله عاصمه جنوب
دارفورد مع تزايد المخاوف بشان احتمال
حدوث ازمه الانسانيه كارثيه مع مئات
الالاف من اللاجئين
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
ما تزال عمليات النهب والسرقه تطالب
المنشات الرسميه والحكوميه السودانيه بسبب
الاقتتال الدائر والانفلات الامنيه الحاصل
في البلاد
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه رصد العربيه بعضا
من مشاهد النهب التي طالت وزاره التربيه
والتوجيه في جنوب دارفور هذه هي وزاره
التربيه والتوجيه بجنوبه دارفور تم
الاعتداء عليها تماما وتم تدمير كل
المكاتب والاقسام الخاصه بالامتحانات
والخاصه بعمل التربيه والتوجيه هنا في
جنوب دارفور جنوب دارفور فيها تتم طباعه
جميع الامتحانات لاقليم دارفور تم تدمير
كامل لجميع ماكينات الطباعه في هذه
الوزاره كما تم نهب جميع الاجسام داخل هذه
الوزاره دمار كبير للبنيه التحتيه
والتربويه والتعليميه في جنوب دارفور
يحتاج العمل لاعاده هذا المكان الى طويل
الخسائر لا حصر لها حتى الان تواصل اللجان
عملها لحصر الخسائر المتعلقه بعمليات
السلب والنهب داخل الوزارات المختلفه ايضا
تم نهب وزاره الماليه بالولايه ومراكز
تتبع للصحه مثل الصحه الايجابيه ومركز
التحصين ووزاره الصحه وغيرها من المرافق
الحكوميه الهامه في جنوب دارفور
قالت مسؤوله الاتصالات الاقليميه في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي للشرق افريقيا ان
طرفي الصراع في السودان بحاجه الى
الاجتماع معا لايجاد حل للنزاع حيث ان
الاشتباكات المستمره قد تؤثر سلبيا على
جميع انحاء المنطقه
بالنسبه لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي فان همنا
الاكبر في الوقت الحالي هو اذا لم يتوقف
الصراع في السودان قريبا فسيكون التاثير
السلبي في جميع انحاء المنطقه كبيره نحن
نرى فعليا ما لا يقل عن عشرين الف لاجئين
عبروا الحدود الى تشاد زملائنا يقولون
ايضا ان العدد مشابه في جنوب السودان ان
لم يكن اكثر يعبروا الى جنوب السودان نحن
نفكر في اللاجئين الموجودين في السودان
وكيف يمكنهم العوده الى بلدانهم الاصليه
غير المستقره اصلا كما ينبغي ان تكون عند
عودتهم لذا فان التاثير المضاعف للمنطقه
كبيره انه مصدر قلق الحقيقي ونحتاج فقط
الى ايجاد السلام فنحن بحاجه الى ان يجتمع
طرفات صراعي معا ويجدوا طريقه لحل لان ذلك
قد يؤدي الى زعزعه استقرار المنطقه
باكملها
من جانبه قال الرئيس للرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ان تدفق العديد من
السودانيين الى مصر سيخلق صعوبات في
البلاد السيسي اشار الى ان بلاده ستتاثر
بشكل واضح بالنساء في السودان في حاله
تدفق المزيد من اللاجئين خاصه ان مصر
تعاني من صعوبات اقتصاديه في ظل الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كما اضاف ان مصر في
الاصل استقبلت حوالي تسعه ملايين لاجئ من
السودان وليبيا وسوريا واليمن ودول اخرى
لنتابع الاوضاع الميدانيه في الخرطوم ينضم
الينا من هناك الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه عمار
اهلا بك معنا كيف هو الوضع الان في
الخرطوم خاصه بان الصوره العربيه دائما
تعطينا دخان يتصاعد من منطقه معينه من
الخرطوم منذ بدء هذه الهدنه يعني على
الرغم من الالتزام فيها في بعض الاحيان
ولكن هذه المنطقه دائما هذا الدخان يعني
سمائها مليئه بهذا الدخان كيف هي الاوضاع
الان
نعم ميسون يعني هذه الاعمده التي تتصاعد
للدخان هي من محيط مطار الخرطوم وقبل قليل
كان هنالك تحليق للطيران الحربي وطائرات
الاستطلاع ردت عليها عدد من المضادات
الارضيه التي تنتشر في المنطقه والخاصه
بقوات الدعم السريع هذا الحريق ربما كان
لعدد من الاشتباكات التي دارت قبل ساعات
من الان وكان هنالك قصف جوي لمناطق محدده
داخل هذا المحيط محيط القياده العامه
للجيش ومحيط مطار الخرطوم وما زالت هذه
الحرائق تندلع في هذه المناطق ونستمع ما
بين فينا واخرى لعدد من التفجيرات في هذه
المنطقه واطلاق لعدد من الاعيره الناريه
وضع يبدو
ولكن هل ما زالت مقفله ام فتحت وعاده
الحياه الى طبيعتها هل يمكن القول ذلك
نعم يعني الجسور الرابطه ما بين مدينه
الخرطوم العاصمه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
ومدينه بحري هنالك عدد من الجسور مغلقه
ولكن بالجانب الشرقي يعني اذا تحدثنا عن
جسر صوبا وجسر المنشيه او جسر الشرق النيل
هذان الجسران يعملان ولكن بشكل حذر في
الجانب الاخر ما بين مدينه ام درمان
ومدينه بحري هنالك جسر الحلفايه وهذا
الجسر دارت في محيطه عدد من الاشتباكات
ولكنه مازال يعمل ولكن بشكل حذر جدا في
الجانب الاخر ما بين مدينه ام درمان
ومدينه الخرطوم وسط العاصمه عدد من الجسور
مغلقه ولكن هنالك معلومات وردت الينا بان
جسر الفتيحاب وهذا جسر يربط ما بين
المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه ام درمان
والمنطقه ربما الشرقيه الجنوبيه من مدينه
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم ايضا يعمل ولكن بحذر
شديد هذه الجسور تغذيه عاصم بعمل الحركه
في عدد من الاسواق لعدد معين من السلع رغم
الحديث الكثير عن ارتفاع في الاسعار لهذه
السلعين توفرت في عدد من المناطق وعدد من
الاسواق التي تشهد حركه شبه طبيعيه وهذا
ساهم بشكل كبير في استقرار النسبي لعدد من
المناطق في مدينه ام دومان شكرا لك من
الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
[موسيقى]
معطله بحاجه الحرب
رامز ظروفك الخاصه
نعمل في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم امك
موجوده هنا
بعض الادويه والمعدات
ومع استمرار المعارك في السودان ارتفع عدد
الضحايا المدنيين جراء النساء حيث اعلنت
نقابه الاطباء السودانيه ارتفاع حصيله
الاشتباكات في السودان الى 447 قتيلا
والفين
كشف المدير الاقليمي للاعلام والمناصره في
اليونسف لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا عمار عمار للعربيه عن خساره اكثر
من مليون لقاحا ضد شلل الاطفال والعديد من
الادويه اثر عمليات النهب من مخازن
المنظمه في السودان مؤكده لانقطاع العلاج
لاكثر من 50 الف طفلا يعانون من سوء
التغذيه الحاده
يعني عندها خمسين الف طفل بعاني من سوء
التغذيه الحاد الوخيم انقطعت عنهم العلاج
في مراكز او الرعايه المنقذه للحياه في
المراكز التغذيه التابعه التي تدعمها في
خاصه في مناطق الاشتباكات مواد المنقذه
للحياه فقدت
مليون لقاح ضد شلل الاطفال في في في بعض
المناطق التي نعمل بها وفي دارفور ايضا
بسبب الذي تعرضت اليه يعني مخزننا ومخازن
الشركاءنا ايضا هدنه يجب ان يتم تصبيرها
بشكل كامل ويجب ان تكون مكرونه ايضا
بضمانات امنيه
للمنظمات الانسانيه العامله على ارض
الميدان فهذول الشرطين لحتى تقدر اليونسيف
منظمات انسانيه اخرى ان تقوم بشكل فعال
وشامل وكامل للاستجابه للاحتياجات
الانسانيه الهائله على ارض على ارض
الميدان
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني
اسامه اهلا بك معنا كيف يمكن ان تصف لنا
الوضع بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من هذا الاقتتال
الوضع الصحي هناك والانساني
والله الوضع الصحي والانساني يتدهور يوما
بعد يوم رغم الهدى المتعدده سته هدى لانه
هذه الهدن اول حاجه قصيره واحد اثنين لا
تصحبها اعلان واضح لممرات امنه وضمانات
للعاملين في المجال الانساني
للعمل والوصول الى اماكن
النشاطات
الدوليه
ومثلا الهلال الاحمر السوداني ايضا لديكم
بروتوكول للعمل به عالميه حتى في حال
الاقتتال هذا البروتوكول حتى الان لم
تستطيعوا تطبيقه لانه ليس هناك من ممرات
امنه تابعه لهذا البروتوكول او هذا هذه
الاليه تصلح لها هل تمكنتم من الحديث مع
او تواصل مع طرفي النزاع اقله لتث بيت هذا
البروتوكول حتى تتمكنون من الحركه بامان
هو طبعا هو اكثر من البروتوكول في
التزامات قانونيه زي ما تفضلتي حضرتك
التزامات قانونيه يعني النزاع في السودان
الان القوات الشعب المسلحه وقوات الدعم
السريع ملتزمه
بتطبيق القانون الدولي الانساني لانه
الحاله اللي نحن فيها في السودان الان هي
حسب التوصيف القانوني هي نزاع مسلح داخلي
وبالتالي الطرفين يعلمون تماما نصوص
القانون الدولي الانساني والالتزامات
المتعلقه
بقياده قواعد الاشتباك وقياده النزاعات
المسلحه
المشكله الان والتحدي الاكبر في السودان
واول مره في تاريخ السودان
تكون
المدن او مدينه الخرطوم ولايه الخرطوم
بكاملها في ساحه حرب بمعنى انه العشره
مليون او 11 مليون مواطن الذين يسكنون في
ولايه الخرطوم كلها بمحلياتها السبعه
وبالامتدادات الجنوبيه والشرقيه والغربيه
والشماليه للولايه
ان هم اكثر من 12 مليون يمثلون
25% من اجمالي سكان السودان فلاول مره في
تاريخ السودان تحصل حاجه زي دي انه العشره
مليون يكونوا هم ضحايا نزاعات
عشان كده اصلا ونشوب النزاع المسلح داخل
المدينه افضل مخالف للقواعد واحد اثنين
دلوقتي من قبل الماضي انه النظام مسلح في
السودان في الخرطوم مثلا او داخل المدن ان
احنا على تواصل مستمر مع قيادات الطرفين
قبل اندلاع الازمه يعلم الطرفان جيدا
التزاماتهم القانونيه ويعلم ان الهلال
الاحمر السوداني مؤسسه سودانيه ذات بعد
دولي
هي تساعد الحكومه في العماله الانسانيه
ولكنها محايده ومستقله عن اي طلب ولكن حال
لكن التطبيقات العمليه على ارض الواقع
دائما بيكون فيها اشكاليات الاشكاليه دي
ممكن تتعالج لبروتوكول مسبق ليه لانه
سيناريوهات اللي بتكون موجوده في النزاع
المسلح وفي الحركه بتاعته
يصعب التنبؤ بها حتى الان يعني لم يتم
التعاون معكم من قبل الاطراف
المتقاتله او المتصارعه تجاه هذا
البروتوكول صحيح
هم هم يتعاونوا ما هم الليله لما يقوموا
يعلنوا عن هدنه لتمكين العمل الانساني
وتمكين القواعد الفنيه هي دي مساله كويسه
لكن
جدا ضغط البروتوكول
بتركيزه على ارض الواقع وخصوصا المسارات
الامنه المتفق عليها يعني الطرفين قياده
الطرفين ما عندهم مانع يعملوا مسارات امنه
لكن المشكله في النزاع الحاصل الان انه
كيف تصل هذه التعليمات
والمسارات الامنه الى افضل جندي موجود
داخل العاصمه
طبعا المساله دي بتحصل في العالم كله
دائما
النزاعات المسلحه الداخليه
دائما بتحصل فيها
مناطق الامريكيه تحصل فيها لخبطه
برغم الاعلان اطراف النزاع في معظم
الحالات تعطي نزاعات الداخليه في العالم
كله انه بيكونوا توفيه نظام ملتزمين
بالقانون وعايزين يطبقوا القانون لكن
المسائل من يدهم لما يكون النزاع داخل
وخاصه
الحاصل في الخرطوم شكرا ابو بكر
المنام الهلال الاحمر السوداني كنت معي من
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات